even in your nose you can be a carrier
for many different things so I shouldn't
eat my boogers no eat well actually no I
think that eating your boogers are fine
because your stomach acids are just
gonna destroy that [ __ ] Oh salty yeah so
what so if you because I know an
Australian guy who would drink pee yeah
pee eventually you would have a buildup
of ammonia in your system and that would
eventually probably be toxic to you
and it would affect your brain somehow
but the likelihood of getting sick from
one time drinking your pee is not as
severe as eating your own [ __ ] I don't
have a [ __ ] like what about this
whatever if I was at surge I think I
heard this before where surgeon was you
know deserted on an island and he had a
surgery stuff a wood peel parts of his
skin I like meat off his body to eat it
yeah to survive Wow
Sencha Lee he was just a nub man like
okay that's what I would do I would
shoot up I just shooting myself up with
more feet yeah I would probably if I
could probably and coherently dress my
own wound and make sure there was no
infection yes I I would do that but what
he does is he's opening himself up for
sepsis and eventually having that wound
become infected but if he has everything
to make sure it doesn't get infected
yeah then yeah I guess theoretically
that would make sense oh I see so we had
antibiotics all that kind of stuff yeah
but still let's say you're in a very
humid area you're not you can't keep
clean you're not you don't have access
to water
you don't cartoony islands you'd see in
cartoons where it's just a mound of land
and one one palm tree it is a man laying
against that in a situation like that
you're probably dead then for sure yeah
and unless you're me and you can like
spear fish and stuff yeah but if you
know but it but in in a small little
island like just little island the size
of this room for instance yeah you have
a tree in the middle of this room you're
[ __ ]
because especially when you don't have
access to water you can't drink ocean
water yeah you're [ __ ] yeah or you
could do this if it's rainy you can
drink the leaves off the water like use
the leaves as a
recep receptacle to capture the water
yeah if you let's if it is a rainy
island but if it's like [ __ ] like you
know if that's assuming that you're in a
very you know precipitous environment
yeah okay just FYI just want to know it
was I'm also I also did see one time
that there a man I don't know who it was
there is a way to separate the salt from
sea water I think it's just a little bit
harder so you're not gonna ingest all
that like a question calm you want an
eight year old I think that's only nine
calories and their protein there's got
to be protein there guys swimming in
there but I think it's only nine
calories how is that gonna [ __ ] you is
that cannibalism eating your own nuts
yeah your own child
no you do that now I know you smell and
taste it every time I know
[Music]